Bobby fiser had other things in plan and
he played what a lot of people perceive
to be the greatest sacrifice in chess
history and he brought his Bishop
to E6 now if you came up with this move
I don't believe you because I looked at
this game a long time um and you may be
a better chess player than I am but
there's no way that I'm playing E6 in
this chess game but Bobby fiser is
better at chess than I am um and he did
play it even at 13 he was better than I
will ever be so uh he played Bishop to
E6 and burn decided to go ahead and take
the queen again if you have a queen you
know it's it's pretty hard not to take
so he went ahead and took the queen and
then Bobby fiser went ahead and played
Bishop to C4 and then just started a
windmill tactic and just started
gobbling up all of Burn's pieces